you don't just have a legal fight chris
you've got a pr
fight and the pr fight began before
the legal fight has started the pr fight
reached a full boil yesterday when in a
coordinated approach on social media
one player after another chastising the
league
for refusing to provide a safe workplace
and it was coordinated by byron jones
the dolphins cornerback who signed
therein free agency and it was one star
player
after another calling out the league for
the failure to get this safe workplace
in position guys have family issues
russell wilson for example his wife's
pregnant he doesn't want to bring the
virus home to her other players who
either have medical conditions or their
family members have medical conditions
and look i don't know that a sunday
afternoon
is the ideal time to do that maybe they
would have waited until
you know a week day or maybe you should
have done today or friday
but but you know they want to get the
attention to league because they need to
get these procedures in place that
everybody feels good about because
all of the dates are popping up on the
calendar and guys have to show up to
work so the sooner they get the league's
attention
the better yeah well of course and it is
it's a it's a great effort
orchestrated by byron jones like you
said i mean yeah you know the players
got to get their voice out there you're
right because in the court of public
opinion
we know how this is going to go it's
going to be you know you're going to
hear the people oh you're
you're getting paid to play football oh
screw you screw your life go play
football i want to watch it on sunday
like
okay yeah yeah but i got a family and
it's more than football and
you know that's just not the right
approach so the players are getting out
in front of it
they're putting the pressure on the
league they're letting everybody know
with these tweets right now that
hey we're willing to play we're willing
to get in the scrum
and sweat and bleed on each other and do
all those things that you're not
supposed to do
as long as you can just you know take a
little extra coin and do the right
things to protect us
you know on the way in and on the way
out of the building on a daily basis
but i just again i don't understand how
the players can agree on anything
until they see something more
substantial in a protocol
that's gonna make them feel that way i
mean sorry you know yeah basketball can
play in a bubble right now they're gonna
they're in the playoffs basically
so it's not gonna be a long time you
know the nfl teams can't leave their
families for
for five months until january or if
you're in the playoffs until early
february and just say oh
you know the hell with my family the
hell with my kids being born i don't
need to see any of it
i'll stay in a bubble no that's not
realistic and it's it's not fair
so yeah something more needs to be done
there on that
on that aspect and that's where i just
go i think we need to still buy time
here because of where we are as a
country
you know i don't think players are going
to be in shape worth a damn mic when
they get there i think player you know
coaches are going to get them in they go
all right whoa i mean this guy hasn't
done anything yeah he did some curls for
the girls and the
weight room and his his his pecs look
good but he's not ready to play football
and i i think there's going to
need a a certain time there to let guys
get
ready and get their feet underneath them
for the safety in that aspect as well
for the players
and that's a separate issue yes it is
from whether or not yes the virus
will be properly accounted for in the
procedures the nfl puts in place but
you're right
there is a concern that if players get
rushed the the injury rate is going to
be even higher than it was in 2011
when 25 percent more injuries happened
without the benefit of an off-season
program one of the things when we had jj
watt on pftpm during the hiatus
he said back then he was a rookie at the
time guys could still work out they
could go to the gym
they could work out in groups they could
work out together yes
this time around it's harder for some
guys you know they live in an apartment
complex the gym there is shut down
they can't go to the local gym they
really have much they can do to get into
the kind of shape they need to be in
when they show up so they want to have a
gradual period where everyone gets into
the shape they need to be in before they
start doing the kinds of things they
ordinarily do
now one of the reasons why the nfl
has been disinclined to give in on the
various things the players want
is the nfl knows deep down
chris something you've been saying for
months that when push comes to shove
the players are going to play they're
not going
to balk at whatever these rules are they
just want to play football and
they don't care about the virus and
that's
that you know that was the big takeaway
from the ol mastermind summit that
happened
last weekend between this most recent
weekend and
and uh fourth of july down in dallas
and the videos were shot and there
weren't a whole lot of masks
and there wasn't any social distancing
and it culminated in a hot wing eating
contest where a bunch of guys were
clustered together
with no masks on seeing who could eat
the most hot wings
when the league sees that the league
says
we we got these guys they don't care
about the virus
we don't have to go over and above we
don't have to listen
to all these things that nflpa
leadership is urging us to do
because when it comes down to it these
guys don't care about the virus
and now the teams care because they want
their players to be available
but if you have a disagreement you know
if the nfl's at this level and the nflpa
wants to be at this level
the nfl doesn't need to move from the
lower level because
the fear isn't real right it's not as
widespread
as the nflpa would have them believe
look at the tom brady
worked out exactly when the union said
stop it he kept doing it and you know
what
one of the guys who wasn't in on
yesterday's coordinated
effort to get the league's attention was
tom brady
i would say that maybe they decided to
leave him out because his behavior
cuts against his push right the safest
possible environment yeah right i mean
he's not exactly the poster child you
want for the guy to say hey we want
things done safely when we know he
hasn't been exactly safe himself and
then
the owners can point at it and be like
what are you talking about that guy's a
hypocrite so
i would i would think that he was left
out of that deliberately
uh or maybe he's just on vacation either
way but i would think there's something
there to that
he's he was on he was not no he wasn't
he was weak he was here
he was he posted yeah he posted
something yeah he's around all right yep
so then he's hey what do you mean if
you're on vacation everybody's got their
phone
i know but sometimes people just go off
radar you know and he's might be in
brazil or costa rica or
something like that so i just don't know
yeah i know they do
i know they do but uh i i and again you
know mike yes you're exactly right that
online summit
just it proved the point that i'd been
trying to say all spring
but i think still the big thing is it's
not about that it's not that
that's really going to come down to it
more than not i mean again
i think it's the players are going to be
more worried about family
issues like that everything to go along
with that and then hey the nfl
it's all fine and dandy right hey cool
yeah a bunch of o-linemen they want to
play a bunch of guys that maybe
you know a lot of us don't know who were
sitting on the couch watching on sunday
i don't know who that special teams guy
is blah blah blah
but you know hey when russell wilson and
maybe some aaron donalds and some
patrick mahomes of the world start
telling you they're not playing football
until things are different
i bet you the nfl owners and everybody
perks up a little bit and i think it's
going to have to continue to be a little
bit what we saw yesterday
the onslaught from the big names from
the big players in the league the stars
yes drew brees i know he got involved
yesterday everybody
it's gonna have to be those type of
players they have the voices
they're gonna have to make sure they get
their message out in the mainstream
media
and to the public so they can keep the
pressure on on the owners
hey again the owners are rich as hell
their
their teams are appreciating the players
have a short career
and they're taking all the risk here
all of it the owners are going to be
sitting in a at home
or in their box with nobody around them
the players are taking all the risk
so sorry they get a bigger piece of the
pie this year we didn't think this was
going to happen
it's unforeseen sorry nfl owners you
don't have a forced major clause
in your contract what the hell were you
thinking
and the players have the power here and
i think it's going to be on the owners
here to buckle at some point and
you know make sure things are right yeah
and that goes to the financial side of
this the absence of a forced major
clause in the cba and
you know we've said this before anytime
there's something that
is or isn't in the cba that works to the
disadvantage
of the nfl players association there are
plenty of people in the media who puff
out their chests and point a finger at
the union and say
shame on you for not for not addressing
that you had every chance to address
that in the cba
well when it comes to enforced major
clause shame on the nfl
for not putting one in there right
because there isn't one
and they're trying to make one on the
fly what they're trying to do
is as part of this broader financial
issue go to the union
and say we want 40 million per team in
salary and benefits
back for this year because hey they're
not going to have fans
or many fans at most if not every game
they are going to lose that money
and then we want the rest of the
financial losses to be accounted in
next year's salary cap now there is a
duty under the cba
if there is a significant reduction in
revenue due to an issue like this to
have good faith negotiations about what
the cap will be next year
but it has no effect on what the players
would do to make this year and if you're
a guy who's in the last year of his
career like a drew brees
most likely is do you want to give up
any of your 25 million
right but when you know that if if the
reckoning comes next year and you're
retired it's not your issue
or or just if for any guy in the nfl you
don't know what tomorrow's going to
bring
push it out into the future that's what
the union is trying to get the league to
do
the union wants the financial losses to
be smoothed out from 2022
through 2030 a nine year window where
the
and you're gonna have more tv money and
there's gonna be an increase in gambling
revenue because all these states are
gonna try to rebuild their budgets by
legalizing sports betting that's the way
to tuck those losses
into the cracks and people won't even
notice that and it doesn't
penalize the players who are taking the
risk
of playing in a pandemic that's what's
astounding to me
you shouldn't take a dollar from these
guys if anything you should pay them
more
for playing this year chris i agree you
know mike here here's the other
curveball of this
and i know you wrote about this at some
point during the weekend i can't
remember
what day it was you know your copy paste
copy paste snarky comments so much don't
lose
that don't stop no you're gonna you're
gonna be touching on something that is
no copy no paste
something that we obtain that no one
else has that gets into the details of
the ability of a player to say
i'm out is that what you're talking
about yeah that and i think too
you know if we're going to be fair and
talk about the players and everything
that they're
you know like you said they're they're
taking all the risk
i also look at the players who finagled
their contract to be nice to the
football team and not maybe take a huge
signing bonus or whatever it may be
upfront money in some capacity to where
they might have just gotta
they oh i'm gonna get it in base salary
this year and do things like that
you know that that screws over that
player that guy who
back in march said okay i'll be oh team
you need me to do this for the contract
okay i'll do this blah blah blah they do
it
and now here's another guy who got paid
a bunch of money up front who this
player kind of like
you know tweaked his contract so they
can make it happen
and now here he's gonna get screwed over
you know and i know these are like first
world problems but still it doesn't mean
that the nfl player is out of their
right with some of this
this is a big issue that really hit the
radar screen yesterday where
someone very plugged in to the mindset
of a lot of players especially star
players
said guys are starting to realize that
the league wants to reserve the right to
wipe
out guaranteed money right if there is
any cancellation of games or if there's
no season and these guys are always led
to believe that the fully guaranteed
money is the gold standard that's money
in the bank
right we get that money oh no you don't
maybe you should have had a signing
bonus or an offseason roster bonus
because then you would have had the
money in the bank this money we're going
to take away if we don't have a season
at least that's their proposal now
someone else said there's no way the the
union is going to let the league do that
but but
this is the problem with a union that
represents
a couple of thousand guys who have very
different interest
objectives because not many players
have fully guaranteed salaries for skill
injury and cap where they believe
they're getting that money no matter
what
now all of a sudden the league's saying
well you know what if games are canceled
you're not getting your fully guaranteed
money and the players are saying well
what the hell does fully guaranteed mean
if i don't get my fully guaranteed money
that's something that a lot of star
players have very recently
realized and maybe that had something to
do with so many star players
getting involved yesterday but that's
another thing that needs to get
needs to get worked out because guys
feel like chris they're going to have
money taken
out of their pockets that they thought
was already earned was guaranteed
it's not guaranteed if the nfl has their
way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports